reject well ah hi hi thank you very much
for that warm introduction I wasn't sure
or you know you know ignoring the email
for two weeks and it wasn't two months
it was two weeks I let it I didn't apply
to it you know things get stuff on hi
lee juck's yes wow this is the last talk
I'm so sorry I'm the one in between fine
and the tiring talk I hope this is a
little entertaining because a little bit
of different thing and I promise there
will be JavaScript but not much about
JavaScript so my name is Michael you may
know me from this form of Twitter that's
my handle that's my other door currently
this is the first time I'm actually
saying this in public I do textile thing
in JavaScript and yeah thank you and
it's funny that at the conference people
actually like comes up to me saying it
oh you are the Knitting person what do
you actually do for living I'm a Jason
jr. at a company called scripto which is
an awesome company who lets me decide my
title completely based on my side
project scripto is not a textile company
we make software for TV shows and
awesome company very supportive I get to
spend two weeks here doing textile
research and commuting a commuting to
the company so very grateful for that so
I'm also co-organized with pjs who was
at the intro video for janaki's I again
I have a be low video we took like that
was like past 11pm after a full day of
co-working and meet up and we had a
little drunk we took like maybe full
takes and there's a take of like me
lowing on the floor just like laughing
entire time so if you're interested I
can show you at the party but brookies
you look like this
and what's the awesome is that in New
York not only broken Jess but we have
mahat andreas queen dais Georgie's
clipped so if you visit New York
literally every week we have a
JavaScript hang out so just let me know
when you're in town we'll have a good
time so here's all the organizers of the
bolo j s family we call it and we i am
very very proud of what we built in new
york community this year we have eight
speakers coming into vjax ases s calm
and jazz conf so very proud of
supportive network that we built so what
am I talking about today I want to talk
about CS and you might think that like
oh ok CS computer science no I don't
want to talk about computer science
computer science makes me sad and gray I
want to talk about crafts I hands that
kind of cs and the cross science looks
like this and this is something I've
been doing for a few years more a bit ly
and extensively for past few months
which is I do this intersection of
coding and crafting which mainly for
myself my project is a knitting there is
a little bit of background to why or how
I came to this intersection so I was a
hung nado first I wasn't engineer first
I learned in it when I was seven maybe
once a year I make like a little scarf
and it was something that wasn't like
serious hobby but like a light hobby
that I do every year four years ago I
moved to New York City I didn't have a
work visa so I had nothing to do and I
was so bored that bored enough to put
myself into learning to code um I've
been in tech industry for my career and
I was a p.m. so like I was comfortable
with like talking about tiki stuff but
never got around actually learning to
code but I was bored enough to put
myself into JavaScript tutorial and
doing that i noticed that like Oh
javascript is actually helpful for my
knitting and I dug up the tweet that I
do member that I tweeted about this and
it's in Japanese so you can't leave you
lead it maybe some of you can but it's
hang that like oh I need a discount
erful project that I'm doing to keep
track of like how many lows that I knit
I learned java script so in 30 minutes i
use the plaza and dom and that was super
useful fun that's 2013 8 months before i
get a job as a javascript engineer so
when i'm doing knitting in the
JavaScript learning JavaScript I noticed
there is a correlation between needing
and coding and knitting is very binary
processed much like programming is ones
and zeros atomic unit for knitting is
two stitches the type of stitches knit
stitch and purl stitch and you can see
there that there is a two distinct face
of the fabric that they produce so if
you look if you have a sweater you can
just look at the pattern of it it is a
combination of knit or purl stitches in
here represented as a KO key so the two
by two living that's all sometimes using
the cuff of your sweater or neckline is
a to knit stitches to purl stitches and
the one on the left is a little more
into get pattern but if you just closely
look at it it is the alternate KPK p
slightly shifting to the left on top of
that the instruction of how to make
scarf or how do you make a sweater comes
in this form and to me it looks a lot
like code there is like a leap heating
letters and maybe some kind of valuables
there is a more explicit loop happening
like knit until two stitches remaining
goalie Pete from spar to the end so that
means you can knit in JavaScript because
knitting is code so let's take a look at
this pattern for the first line says co5
and let's just do it in JavaScript socio
means cast on and that means that just
create a space so that you can start
it's not a stitch yet so it's kind of
like you're cleaning empty LA but like
links of five and casting on so next
line is k 5 and k stands for knit stitch
and 5 means how many times you need to
do it so that means this line is saying
like knit five stitches
so I cleated the value of okay who is
litter capital k and they placed a low
zero with 5 case in it fallout you put
it into my scarf parent LA and now you
need it one low in JavaScript the second
line gets a little tricky so the thing
about knitting is that it's Oh episode
on the needle so the previous la the
links of the previous la always inherit
it to the next low like you can't start
the five stitches and then next low be
100 stitches well technically there is a
way to do it but like a little more
complicated so you inherit the links
from the previous low could a new la and
then from there you count how many
stitches and what to do so the first one
we already know k 2 means knit two
stitches so I put knit stitches count up
the index so now you have a two stitches
in your La next one is a new concept m1
which is make one stitches and it's a
lot like operating the splice method on
yo la and putting in like another
element into your la so like you know
past the index where you are put the new
stitches now the LA is length of 6 and
then here you have a loop and it's
saying that how many ever you have on
your needles just knit until last
remaining two stitches so in this case
you only put one stitches but you do the
while loop until the remaining stitches
or two and next one we already did that
like same thing like eating make one now
your legs it's seven and then you two
now your second law is complete push it
through the my parent my scarf away and
now you have to erase or to lowes of
knitted fabric there so continue in
doing that it looks like this to create
a triangle-shaped scarf and what I
always thought was that the meaning is
like you are compiling your code or
knitting pattern in your brain
interpreting it and then executing the
computation on your hand and needles so
that the flea yarn that the yambo is a
flea memory and then the fabric is
allocated memory
now do you ugly that the knitting is
like coding yeah yeah on top of that
when you're designing your own knitted
fabric it is a lot like math like
calculator is your friend you need a
graph paper Here I am deciding on the
design of the slope of the armhole and
then trying to decide how to decrease it
so that it comes naturally to my bus
line and you need to fit it in fit the
patterns into a certain public the
Allstate it's a lot turns into like a
puzzle because you don't want the nice
piece of pattern to be ended on the side
you want it to be center so I enjoy that
and I have a tendency that like if I
like something I just go to you like
that thing forever and I don't sleep and
then go like deep deep down down there
so like Eileen II wanted to investigate
a lot of Potter making a lot of knitting
I found although hun inning takes time
and then I found the machine code
knitting machine which lets me make
public way faster than I hum net and
this is me creating a scarf that I have
in here but it's basically a machine
that lets me do my job faster it is not
a new thing my machine is from 80s and
these machine has been around things
1500 my machine turned out to be a
electro knit which is a computer
operated machine that lets me send the
data into the machine so that I can
program the pattern and I did a little
bit of a project about taking a digital
photo image turning in to bitmap image
turning into ones and zeros away turn it
into that file by bit shifting and then
printing out in my knitting machine and
I gave a talk about that at rjs conf us
past May and if you have any question or
if you want to know more about how i did
it i'm happy to talk so later but today
i will talk about what came after that
project so my machine was the first one
to have a computer operated version but
the version before was using
being cold punch guard and I have it
here and in investigating how knitting
machine works I was super fascinated
first of all this is [ __ ] beautiful
and I was so fascinated that I can
control the machine by just perforated
paper punch guard and I again go down
the lab at whole of researching
something and I realize that punch cards
are actually cool it touches at some
point of history it touches automation
of the Machine and computation of doing
the bath on the data and then touches a
communication and all of three which I
consider a base of computer and internet
and like what we deal with every day
punch core touch that in history so a
little bit of information let's talk
about like what automation so in 1745
Jack Kevorkian was commissioned by
French government to create an automated
job textile loom for local silk industry
and he was the first one I mean before
that there was like a concept of using a
punch core to operate the machine but he
was the first one to make up for fully
automated loom operated by punch card
didn't get picked up quite well until
1800 when Joseph merely jacquard picked
up the project and then included and
created this famous loom called jacquard
loom side note it's interesting that the
the British text Islanders were an
industry was up-and-coming so Napoleon
spend money actually on the local
business the Leon and they got like
increasing number of order so they need
a machine to make those order and he was
commissioned by a merchant and beyond to
clear those machine this is a jacquard
loom that I just took part of my
research trip to textile museum in
Netherland this is how it works it's
feeding the punch card and then
selecting the thread in the machine to
create a textile pattern and here's a
jiff animation from five years animation
from Victoria and Albert Museum
basically upon score gets pushed Lords
are pushed or not pushed
and then the Slayer attached to that is
picked up by and then wait for it goes
down there to show yes this is how
pixels or select it so this is another
fine from the textile museum it is
discussing mechanism of the jacquard
loom but to me it looks a lot like
explaining how computer graphics and
pixel works and I was like so like
fascinated by that when I found out so
that was just using punch cord to
operate a machine like how about
computation part so cold sackhoff was
the first one to know to use the punch
court as a data storage and he was a
statistician who wanted to do faster
work on his research he proposed this
thing called linear home scope and
basically it is a shelf with the hole
and data in it he pleads a pins kind of
like a query he learns that pin over the
shelf and then if that came matches with
the whole you find the data faster than
going through by hand another one
Charles Babbage from England could he
planned the famous machine analytical
engine which use punch cord as a data
input and Charles Babbage was the one
the Ada Lovelace was exchanging a letter
which we some of you may know that he
became first computer program Lovelace
made a beautiful beautiful quote about
this machine saying the analytical
engine weaves all algebraic patterns
just like a jacquard loom leaves flowers
and leaves like great back in united
states in the united states there was
another attempt to use punch cord for
computation which is by home and hollis
in 1889 he created this machine code
tabulating machine it's basically punch
court's order to sort out data faster
and it came out of need from US Census
so US Census happens every ten years and
the census in 1880 took nine years to
compile that data because they did not
have any
equipment there was a lot of immigrant
coming in they did the hunt compile of
the data and it took nine years so like
why by the time you get old analysis
done you know another sensors what's
happening and it was gonna be problem
the next census so he created the
machine called tabulating machine and
here is a picture of Lady inputting the
data into a punch card by the way the
tabulating machine company through
different acquisition became what is
known as IBM right now and then now it
all makes sense that the IBM machine
punch card it all came from there so the
communications part also attached on the
perforated paper roll punch card before
going to the punch core there's like a
little prehistory 1864 there was a first
telegraph service happening between
Washington DC and New York it used the
piano like keyboard and then two
operators were sitting at the end
appearing the thing and soon they
realized that they need to have a
standard communication way so the bow
dog amilo balda in france created this
five bit five you know ones in zero
system called bout it system and adopted
in france but then in 1901 Donald Murray
was the first one who introduced this
use of perforated paper or punch card as
a part of teletype so what he introduced
was that instead of like typing and
ending the data immediately just type it
into the paper and then create the paper
so so that the papers like those dolls
are queued up and it doesn't basically
the process becomes nonlinear and you
can queue up the data he actually walked
on the bow to code and became what is
known as international Telegraph
alphabet which still use the five bit so
they need it like space to represent all
the letters and they introduce the idea
of shifting and that's why you have a
shift key in your computer so basically
they have a figure and letters and
whenever that the shift two letters
signal happens then after that
everything gets lead as a letters and
then
you see the shift to figure signal
happens then after that everything after
that is lead as a figure of course if
you talk about the encoding system i
have to mention ascii which is American
Standard Code for information
interchange somebody did not really
think about diversity somebody saw 7-bit
is enough letters to the prince and all
the communication letter which is not
enough but they let use the 128
characters but then computer happened
the computers are a bit and like who are
not level of bits now available to you
and there was a lot of multiple
standards like Nordic country started
making their own standards because they
needed their own letters to be
represented country like Japan my home
country decided to this weird thing
called multi-byte encoding which is very
programmatic when you are dealing with
Japanese computer program till this day
um then there was a vodka unicode unique
unified universal encoding and if any of
you want to geek out about like how
awesome you t expect is like i'm more
than happy to do that but not going into
today so i was like after this like holy
search i was like wow that was a lot of
wikipedia lead but then like punch card
is like actually really cool I want to
make one so i quickly prototype dip out
of team foil and nope card and jumper
wires didn't nearly walk out so my part
was that the the jumper wire is a leader
so like kind of like moves through it
and then lead it but didn't really work
i went back to lie collisional drawing
of like how jock Harlan was made and
then like sketched up how it's gonna get
hit down to my friends with job cut some
good measure some things pork some hole
put the contact sheet on it and then
forget to algae we know and then now
that's there so I have that machine here
and I wrote an interpreter so basically
the machine itself is just leading a
data the data and then what to do with
it afterwards up to me as a computer
programmer so i created this demo site
electromechanical the computer by the
way i'm so so
no my domain purchased that was
available by the way doc computer space
wide open you should you should check
that um so I'm going into the demo site
and I have a punch card that made put it
onto the machine on the side and it's
seif since yay so that's ! and this one
that's a little I oh I'm doing demo
backwards it what's supposed to say hi
there
so so I created two demos one is leading
the same la the binary are a turning
into ascii character so you can see the
letters the other one is much like a
jacquard loom trying to create a textile
pattern so a little bit about how this
thing hole gets together each pins that
a pins are buttons so i use it Johnny 5
and then created the eight buttons and
each button has a events / hold all
these so every time the button gets hold
is okay socket i/o to omit the WebSocket
to my server and then same as a release
and every time that event immediate i
send the index of which pin was hold or
live east on the server side it's very
simple i always have a pattern eight
zeros and then whenever socket comes in
we placed our index with one and then
purse that data into ASCII characters on
the demo of the textile side I use the
same LA to see if it's zero create a
white canvas box and then if it's one
create a black canvas box so after this
exercise I was like I finally understand
how code works and computer Lee's my
code this is super cool I can create my
own punch card language in you know
whatever way but then like dealing with
binary is not as friendly as you think
it's just like you are always looking at
art of like binary to hex to octal to
it's just not fun likely as JavaScript
programmers have a way to do this in
JavaScript and skip hole punch card and
binary system which is make your own
parser so this summer I tended the
program called school for poetic
computation and their attended the class
by solid golf Miller called talking to
machines those [ __ ] and it was
basically a class about how to create
your own domain specific language and
how to create a parser for it so I use a
library called Peggy is which is a
parser generator for JavaScript and they
have like nice interface folder online
editing they have a so basically you
create your own glamour in pegs way and
then peg compile it into generator and
then they have a little interactive
tester to see if it works so let's see
they have a simple glamour define and
then in here they have white space
defined so what if I don't want any
white space in my language that I'm
designing so like I just get a little of
that then now the parcel is yelling at
that like I am not expect expecting
white space there is white space so like
I get a little bit then it will say /
successfully so I did this exercise for
my thing and created my own domain
specific language called 64 stitches and
specifically in the purpose to teach
programmers how knitters lead knitting
patterns so the D language itself is
designed to look like exactly like a
knitting pattern instead of using K&P I
use underscore and asterisks to the
present a white space in black space so
that kind of like being able to see it
visually um so let's zoom in if I so
remember when we did the JavaScript
knitting cast on is how how wide the
start with it so if i change that cast
on eight to 16 it's wider width and then
if i go to like a weird one that's like
four then oh it's not the weird it's
like three completely changes the shape
of the pattern and then you can change
that to be completely white low or
completely black low notice that the
until 32 stitches remaining I
specifically Royals parser so that the
programming language that I that user
need to use is a language that the
knitting machine uses so I made that and
I tweeted thinking that maybe 10 of my
friends
nerd about things would like it and I
never expected to get this much positive
feedback um I was never like a popular
JavaScript library programmer so like I
was like wow people are weird people
like weird stuff but it was great a lot
of like London people started tweeting
at me there screen shot of their code
and the pattern because i made the
online app to be interactive so that the
patent that the code itself always gets
compiled every time the key up event
happens and change the pattern so i
added the feature to for those to say
the pattern and here is some example
this user i'm like particularly plow
that at my code or sample was clear
enough that she used loop in her coat
and a lot of people ended up using that
as like a mini pixel orange in the later
so here's a cat here's a skull and
invaders and of course jeaious lighting
my own parser turned out to be great
exercise in learning ideas and computer
science that i never learned because i
did not take computer science which is
abstraction the writing glamour for the
passer is basically like saying like in
English you have like noun and verb and
you know it has to go in a certain order
same thing like I have to define what
castellón is and I have to define what
loop is and then going into smaller
chunks smaller chunks small chunk and
kind of like learn oh this is what
abstraction people are talking about
this is I get it now and also I stopped
being mad at the JavaScript console
yelling at me on the eller because I
learned that the lighting meaningful
eller for the parser is super hard so
now like undefined is not a function I'm
okay with that
so what's next I have no idea I really
don't I'm just like way into this punch
car thing and I want to clean my own
language and now I don't know what comes
next although I have few ideas of what i
wouldn't do next one just [ __ ] put
the code on github I'm like the person
food cleats like empty github repo
saying like this will be this project
and never puts the code in and like I
have no laser vision of putting in
closed source or anything I'm just being
lazy so I'll do that and then next one
is like I want to make an appt for
knitter so this year I've had a great
opportunity a lot of opportunity to talk
to people like you techies about like
how knitting is like a code and how
knitting can teach your computer science
but knitters themselves who does not use
my hack on my code contribute a lot to
what I do which is creating a patterns
cleaning instruction for knitting
machines so I want to make a tool for
them so that they can put more into this
research and nearly what i wanna do is
like explore the idea of like cleft as a
computer science and I'm ed I've never
like computer science until I did this
project and then now I really want to
learn about what computer science is
about so hopefully in past 30 minutes I
convinced you that this picture not only
looks like a class project but looks
like computer science projects you
here's a list of resources that i have
my projects on and the last one is the
one that's empty repo i will put the
code in I have a few samples that I made
all of the scarfs or JavaScript powered
I made it d three [ __ ] put that SPG file
into knitting pattern and then knit it
in you know the file that was created by
javascript and remember that my first
slide that has a lead xjs and kind of
like a glove paper i created a lace
pattern for the lead exeis scarf which i
don't know if you can see can you see
the j logo
here yeah yeah so if you want to see
that happy to show it
and just because i am obligated i have a
broken jess speaker stickers if you want
to come find me thank you very much
reject